[Musik]
hey
meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einer neuen
episode minecraft mit luca staffel 2 der
ein oder andere wird jetzt vor allem
nach der letzten episode wahrscheinlich
erwarten dass wir heute diese hobby
tödliche fertigbauen werden die sache
ist allerdings dass wir das denke ich
leider nicht schaffen werden ich werde
natürlich probieren allerdings ist es
wirklich eine menge arbeit deswegen
verlieren doch gar nicht lange zeit und
fangen direkt an denn ich muss mich hier
erst mal eine nacht blog weiteren gang
reinbauen 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 blöcke haben
wir den gang jetzt lange machte drei
blöcke muss hat ganz so hoch seien die
blöcke hier oben die lasse ich erst mal
dran die müssen zwar nachher auch noch
weg allerdings müssen wir jetzt erstmal
in diese richtung 7 blöcke gehen und in
diese richtung 7 blöcke
so wir haben jetzt hier vorne und hier
vorne alles ausgehöhlt und müssen jetzt
auch noch mal fünf blöcke weiter hier in
den gang eingeben und dann von hier auch
nochmal vier blöcke in diese richtung
hier geben dass hier hinter alles quasi
abbauen den bereich und auf vier blöcke
in diese richtung gehen also dass hier
auch alles abbau jetzt haben wir den
raum an sich schon mal fertig also dass
hier wird so ein bisschen der gang sein
der sich durch die ganze halle
durchzieht dass sie hinten wird das
hinterzimmer seien hier recht so ein
bisschen das schlafzimmer und hier die
küche mit den gegenständen wir werden
heute auch das muss ich ganz ehrlich
schon mal sagen nicht fertig wird dieser
hoffe es wird wirklich sehr sehr sehr
sehr schwer sein das ganze ding hier in
den nächsten folge überhaupt fertig zu
kriegen weil ich für beispielsweise eine
den baustand muss ich schon in die hölle
gehen da war ich ja noch gar nicht dann
benötige ich auch eine menge
bücherregale dafür benötige ich erstmal
auch für ich habe gerade schon wieder
details gehört das glaube ich hier oben
sogar irgendwelche kühe drauf stehen
beziehungsweise den letzten folgen wir
auch eine cola oben gesehen brauchen wir
nur noch eine zweite mit der visite
einfahren können allerdings fehlen halt
uns noch eine menge ressourcen deswegen
müssen wir demnächst erst mal eine
riesen höhlen expedition machen die
sache ist allerdings der sich ja hier
gerade diese beiden seiten schon mal
abgebaut habe das liegt ganz einfach
daran dass wir hier vorne auch das
gleiche mit dem sandstein machen müssen
wie auf der anderen seite also hier
unten kommt noch alles anstellen und
hier dann glatter sandstein die sache
ist allerdings dass ich leider glaube
ich keinen sandstein mehr habe bzw nur
noch so ein ganz kleines bisschen
deswegen muss ich euch direkt nochmal
eine time labs einblenden wie ich mir
sand besorge
[Musik]
so meine lieben freunde ich habe gerade
wirklich eine halbe stunde lang sand
abgebaut weil man ja immer nur aus vier
blöcken sich ein sandstein kriegen kann
das heißt hatte insgesamt vier mal vier
also 16 6 sand habe ich mir abgebaut
plus und top nochmal eine menge
fichtenstämme ich werde jetzt noch ein
bisschen schummeln eigentlich müssen
hier in die ecken nämlich auch sandstein
und sagt was anständig wäre jetzt
einfach mal eher dahin setzen ich weiß
ich bin eigentlich ein fan von so was
allerdings fiel mir echt ein bisschen
die materialien deswegen müssen wir an
jeder ecke und kante gucken wo wir
irgendwie tricksen können hier kommen
jetzt auf jeden fall normale
sandsteinblöcke hin also hier vorne auch
nochmal zack zack kinderecke wieder
tricksen der hier war zu viel getrickst
wegfällt dem und dann hier an der seite
auch wieder ganz normaler sandsteine
bamm bamm bamm bamm und hier wieder ja
dahin die sache ist jetzt dass hier
normale glatte sandsteine hinkommen
müssen die sache ist allerdings dass es
gerade eh schon dunkel wird deswegen
können uns auch direkt mal eben fixieren
unsere kleine hütte bewegen und hier
vorne und ofenkartoffeln raus sind ja
ich wohl noch eingepackt und ich packe
jetzt auch mal ein bisschen sandstein
reise dass wir gleich ein bisschen
glatten sonnenstand vielleicht das ganze
auch noch voll machen und jetzt gehe ich
mal ganz kurz eben schlafen und ein
neuer tag erwartet uns hier in unserer
kleinen süßen minecraft welt obwohl so
klein ist sie eigentlich mittlerweile
gar nicht mehr die alte malte mal
richtig klein weil es da halt bloß ein
paar inseln gehabt die sache ist
allerdings dass wir uns jetzt hier
erstmal eins zwei drei blöcke noch so
perfekte wir bauen uns natürlich nicht
hier drei blöcke weiter sondern von hier
vorne zack zack zack so dass wir hier
dann den eingang haben zu unserem
kleinen hinterzimmer und hier machen wir
jetzt genau das gleiche was wieder vorne
auch gemacht haben nämlich unten kommen
die ganz normalen sandsteine hin und
hier in den ecken können wieder so ein
bisschen tricksen ich werde dann auch
hier vorne noch mal eben kurz
provisorisch eine fackel eben kurz daran
setzen dass wir hier wissen okay hier
kann auch nicht spawnen und so lange wie
der sandstein dahinten jetzt zu glatten
sandstein wird werden wir nun mit
unserer spitzhacke hier den kompletten
boden rausreißt so sieht das ganze auf
jeden fall schon ziemlich gut aus die
sache ist dass wir jetzt allerdings
unsere fichtenholz blätter benötigen
davon habe ich ja hier noch eine menge
drin deswegen schnappe ich mir die
direkt und werde jetzt die den
kompletten boden mit fichtenholz
auskleiden spätestens seit minecraft mit
luca staffel eins wissen ja wie sehr
schlichten holz liebe deswegen wird auch
die decke gleich komplett aus
fichtenholz sein
sache ist allerdings dass ich hier vorne
die höhle erstmal komplett zu bauen wir
können natürlich später noch irgendwann
rein vielleicht kann ich ja noch so eine
kleine wendeltreppe reinbauen allerdings
haben wir jetzt hier erst mal den boden
komplett voll mit fichtenholz brettern
und jetzt schnappen wir uns die teile
die ich im inventar habe sehe ich gerade
und zwar die fichten holzstämme und
bauen damit jetzt hier oben alles voll
da benötigen wir allerdings erst mal
unsere stoffel um hier kurz die pferde
zu entfernen und dann sieht das ganze so
aus ich habe jetzt hier vorne die
blogger in verwahrung gelassen weil hier
kommt er ihn noch glatter sandstein hin
und dann kommen quasi die fichtenstämme
direkt dagegen deswegen macht es keinen
sinn wenn ich das hier entfernt hätte
jetzt nehmen wir auf jeden fall unsere
fichtenstämme und bauen die teile hier
so hin das wird gleich ein bisschen
heller aussehen weil ich die komplett
noch entrinden werde ich hoffe dass
meine angst dass noch mit macht die
sache ist allerdings dass wir das jetzt
erstmal für die komplette pudel hier
wiederholen bzw nicht wiederholen
sondern generell erst mal hier
durchziehen das passt auf jeden fall
perfekt mit den fichtenstämmen ich hab
sie noch 164 sich gerade und jetzt
nehmen uns unsere axt und drehen den
jeden von diesem stämme generell ist
holz einfach so ein unfassbar geiles
material also meine eltern zum beispiel
sind halt voll die fans von stein und
beton und sonnencremes mir gibt das
irgendwie zu wenig wärme aber das wollen
meine eltern auch irgendwie nicht keine
ahnung er sollte auch kein luca eltern
vergleich werden aber holz ist wirklich
wild
auf merge alter ich bin einfach holz in
mainz apropos mörtel allerdings meine
lieben freunde dieser extrem geile blaue
vintage weiter vorne mit einem stück ins
mai die globus optik und hinten
kommt am 11 12 18 uhr
spaß beiseite allerdings freunde
beziehungsweise keinen spaß der kommt
wirklich in shop das sieht auf jeden
fall schon mal sehr wild aus hier mit
dem eingang dass man jetzt ein bisschen
rein gucken kann ich sprinte jetzt
allerdings erst mal hinten in meinem
häuschen und schaut dass mit dem roten
sandstein geklappt hat das sieht auf
jeden fall gut aus da haben wir 32 stück
auf jeden fall da die sache ist
allerdings dass ich definitiv noch mehr
brauche deswegen hab ich das ganze ding
jetzt erst noch mal voll mit kohle und
verbaut an jetzt erst mal nur die 32
glatten sandstein hier vorne an den
wänden so ein bisschen damit die
zumindest sieht in welche richtung das
alles hier gehen soll also hier fordert
somit dem platten land scheint sich auf
jeden fall sehr sehr geil aus die
rollladen hier beziehungsweise diese
eichen büro gleichen
falltüren bleiben auf jeden fall offen
hier vorne geht das dann so lang und
hier dann natürlich so zeigt und hier
vorne auf der anderen seite geht das
dann auch hier so rum
sieg hat noch ein bisschen komisch aus
allerdings müssen wir noch warten bis
der geschäfte jetzt die sache ist
allerdings dass ich mir auch einfach
kurz ich bin ein bisschen bruchsteinen
noch mal eben fix einen zweiten machen
kann und dann kann ich das ganze glaube
ich so ein bisschen beschleunigen ich
habe hier jetzt gerade keine kohle am
start deswegen wäre ich den ofen jetzt
auch hinten mit der spitzhacke erstmal
abbauen hinten immer normales häuschen
setzen da wurde mir auch zahlreich in
die kommentare geschrieben unter dem
letzten video man es macht gar keinen
sinn lukas der gerade diese kleine sich
so bude gebaut fortsetzte höhle ja ich
habe überlegt dass wir dann so ein
bisschen als storage ruhm umzuplanen
aber mal schauen ob das ganze was wird
ich wollte erstmal einen schmelzofen
hier ab so dass ich hier platz für den
ofen habe den schmelzofen packt jetzt
einfach mal hier vorne und unsere stein
kiste rein zack zack zack dann haben wir
die sachen drin und jetzt nehmen wir uns
hier mal die hälfte an kohle raus und
schon anders hier rein so dass wir hier
auch noch uns ein bisschen glatten
sandstein machen können wir gehen jetzt
allerdings erstmal ganz kurzen runde
schlafen während das hier weiter vor
sich hin schmilzt das nehme ich dann
aber ganz fix im ausland kann man schon
mal ein bisschen weiter bauen allerdings
gehören wir uns dann erst mal so lange
wie der grazer sandstein noch benötigt
um unseren eingang soll ein bisschen
haben noch immer nicht eine richtige tür
deswegen werde ich mir jetzt erstmal
kurz meine fichtenholz tür schnappen und
meine fichtenholz falltüren ich weiß
nicht wo ich die hingelegt habe
die beiden wenn wir uns jetzt auf jeden
fall schnappen und jetzt werden wir
zunächst einmal unsere zürcher
vornherein setzen was mich ein bisschen
stört ist dass hier
dass man hier sieht
jetzt müssen wir warten ist das wieder
zu gras wird so dass wir hier ein
vernünftigen trampelpfad ausmachen
können die sache ist allerdings dass das
jetzt schon ein bisschen bisher aussieht
und wenn er die tür schließen sich das
ganze so aus und das gibt einem quasi
diese doppelte tiefe einmal hierdurch
und dann nochmal hierdurch deswegen
gehen wir jetzt allerdings erstmal rein
nehmen uns die fichtenholz falltüren
umplatzieren die hier so dran das sieht
jetzt vielleicht auf den ersten blick
ist ein bisschen komisch aus wenn man
die dann allerdings ein klappt sieht das
ganze deutlich geiler aus mit der tür
hier vorne drin die fackeln dann ziehe
ich jetzt erst mal hier und hier kurz an
der seite und das hat auch direkt gar
keinen sinn gemacht weil wir hier vorne
unsere fichtenholz bretter nicht drei
blöcke weit ziehen müssen luca sondern
zwei also die fackel hier kommt auch weg
zack zack zack erst mal provisorisch
dann hier noch mal kurz eine fackel
hinsetzen und hier auf der seite bauen
wir auch zwei blöcke mit den pflichten
holzbrettern und dann in diese richtung
hier auch ich werde jetzt mal ganz kurz
meinen glatten sandstein nehmen
zumindest das hier schon mal so ein
bisschen zu bauen damit wir jetzt schon
mal sehen wie der raum dann
schlussendlich auch hier hinten ab
geteilt wird und die restlichen daten
sandsteine nehme ich dann jetzt erstmal
für den raum hier vorne weil wir den
zuerst füllen werden also hier die
glatten sandstein der anzag einer fehlt
natürlich perfekt das ist allerdings
nicht weiter schlimm denn wir schnappen
uns jetzt erstmal unsere fichtenholz
treppen natürlich in dem das auto immer
schön verschließen dass keine monster
einkommen und jetzt werden wir hier das
gleiche bauen was wir auch am eingang
gemacht haben so dass das ganze einfach
so ein bisschen rund aus sieht man kann
natürlich runde material in minecraft
nicht selbst allerdings sieht das so
und so und vor allem hier vorne auch mit
den fichtenwald türen schon mal deutlich
geiler aus und genau das gleiche mit den
fichtenholz falschen werden wir dann
auch hier vorne drinnen bauen also sagt
dass einmal auf der seite bamm bamm bamm
bamm bamm und genau das gleiche auch
hier denn hier werden wir jetzt
selbstverständlich auch unsere
fichtenholz treppen in jede seite setzen
und dann natürlich auch hier an die
seiten wieder fichtenholz falltüren nun
muss ich mal eben kurz schauen ob ich
hier vorne reichen stämme drin habe ja
perfekt dann nehme ich mir nämlich
direkt fünf stück raus denn eichenstämme
sind von innen deutlich heller als
fichtenstämme und die werde ich jetzt
einfach hochkant hier einsetzen und dass
man so eine art nicht teppich hat weil
es ist halt holz aber das ist halt
einfach so aussieht
ist finde ich auch ganz schön ich wusste
jetzt generell erst mal alles ein
bisschen ausleuchten und ich werde mich
jetzt auch noch mal ganz kurz eben hin
eine kleine hütte bewegung noch mal nach
dem glatten sunshine gucken denn für das
nächste was wir vorhaben ist auf jeden
fall wichtig dass der sandstein fertig
ist denn wir müssen ja ich bin bei einer
stunde
ja ich habe in zweieinhalb stunden und
ich muss dieses video hier noch
schneiden wisst ihr was freunde wir
werden jetzt zu machen dass ich jetzt
hier einmal den glatten sand schon noch
raus nehme das noch eben kurz verbauen
werde und dann nur noch schnell das
gröbste machen werde ich wollte euch
eigentlich meine tabletten wie ich mir
nachher noch im kessel mache und keine
ahnung was alles solche ganzen sachen
oder eine steigen segel weil die ganzen
sachen benötige ich halt auch noch hier
für die ganze möbel und inneneinrichtung
generell die sache ist allerdings dass
ich das zeitlich nicht mehr hinbekommen
ich hätte nicht gedacht dass ich so
lange am farmen bin für sand und so
weiter und so fort also ich hoffe ihr
entschuldigt mich ich habe ja schon
gesagt dass es wahrscheinlich mehr als
noch eine folge dauern wird diese hobby
tödliche fertigzustellen und leider ist
es jetzt auch so geworden ich werde hier
allerdings noch mal eben kurz das alles
so ein bisschen voll bauen das kriegen
wir jetzt auch hier mit dem glatten
sandstein bam bam bam so war es auf
jeden fall fertig sollte jetzt auch
nicht so nicht jetzt mal auf nummer
sicher sicher sitzen hier nochmal zwei
fackeln dran die die fackel der mitte
sollte ausreichen die sollte ausreichen
und die und jetzt kann ich mich nur noch
schnell um das gröbste was will ich
erstmal benötigen um zwar zunächst
einmal zwei betten die ich mir hier
vorne kurz kräftig ab und auf zack und
sagt dann habe ich auch das zweite bett
das hier habe ich hier schon wieder
hingestellt weil wir ganz einfach
ja hier auch so ein bisschen was drin
brauchen was ein bisschen cool aussieht
ich könnte jetzt auch den rüstungs
stände hier mitnehme ich will ihn
eigentlich dahin stehen lassen ich muss
jetzt mal ganz kurz schauen was wir hier
vorne haben hier ist auch eine rüstung
ständer den nehme ich jetzt einfach mal
mit ich weiß dass ich den eigentlich
nicht klauen wollte allerdings wenn wir
beide clown fällt dem vielleicht nicht
auch da denkt er hätte vielleicht gar
keinen deswegen habe ich die beiden
jetzt auch einfach mal direkt mitnehmen
und zeigen was sich damit vor habe denn
die sollen in mein schlafzimmer von der
hobbit öde hier rechts ist ja mein
schlafzimmer es ist schon echt gut aus
ich bin sehr happy damit vor allem dass
sich alles so ein bisschen wut hat
mittlerweile da müssen noch warten bis
das zu gras will ich weiß ja das klappt
mit dem rosenstrauch daneben allerdings
werde ich hier erst mal diese beiden
blöcke abbauen sagt die gönne ich mir
auch direkt und diese beiden blöcke denn
hier unten werde ich jetzt zwei fackeln
reinsetzen darüber zwei fichtenholz fall
schön dann seht ihr schon wenn ich das
hier abbau dass dadurch so ein bisschen
licht schimmert das ist jetzt natürlich
blöd hier
da brauche ich dann stein satten steines
geholt freunde also mal ganz kurz eben
hier die fichtenholz fall schön wieder
abbauen perfekte direkt runter gefallen
einmal kurz hoch hier eine fichtenholz
brett hin dann hier die beiden
sandsteine eben kurz rein platzieren bam
bam das liegt natürlich an meinem text
apec dass die blöcke sich so ein
bisschen ineinander übergehen ist auch
ganz cool solche situationen allerdings
nicht so super gemacht die jetzt nehmen
wir uns die beiden rüstungs ständer
allerdings und setzten die hier und hier
hin so dass wir hier dann ein wenig
rüstung draufpacken können ich werde das
jetzt einfach mal tauschen gegen meine
rüstung wenn meine schon so ein bisschen
kaputter ist dann können wir
beispielsweise das auch tun hier das
hearing zur um sollen bücherregale handy
habe ich allerdings noch nicht deswegen
konzentrieren wir uns erstmal auf die
betten die soll nämlich hierhin und dann
das andere bett direkt daneben hier
vorne kommt dann noch so ein kamin hin
den kann ich auch noch mal ganz kurz
bauen dafür benötige ich nämlich noch
mal hier kurz ein lagerfeuer und die
anderen blöcke habe ich unten schon im
inventar und zwar vier birken
holztreppen und ein birkenholz vier
birken holztreppen und einwirken
holzbrett so genau das habe ich nicht
gesagt jetzt müssen wir das ganze mich
ein bisschen komisch hinsetzen und zwar
hier und hier eine treppe dann die
treppen da jetzt so ein bisschen komisch
drauf und zwar so und so und hier vorne
einen birken holzbrett noch drauf und
hier kommt an das lagerfeuer an hier
unten könnte ich sogar noch eine
birkenholz stufe hin packen da muss ich
mal ganz kurz gucken ob nicht dass hier
vorne noch machen kann ja genau hier
habe ich sogar direkt noch welche da
nehme ich mir direkt alle noch mit und
dann würde ich tatsächlich an der stelle
meine lieben freunde die heutige episode
mein flug als auch beenden das hier ist
der kamin das sieht auf jeden fall sehr
geil aus generell sieht ist so schon
ziemlich eingerichtet ausgekommen noch
bilder dran bücherregale hier noch ein
bisschen deko hier kommt die bücherei
mit den ölfilm und braus stand und so
weiter und so fort und hier kommt
lagerraum rein
lagerraum rein und so weiter und so fort
wir sind auch schon oben rechts auf der
minimap dass sie anscheinend auch ein
höhlensystem drunter ist das heißt wir
können hier vielleicht dann auch noch
eine kleine treppe runter machen in die
höhle allerdings machen wir das alles in
der nächsten episode bzw dürft ihr
entscheiden was hier nächste episode
machen soll soll ich weiter hier dran
bauen oder sondern erstmal der höhle
gehen ein bisschen weiterkommen projekt
die sonne geht auch schon wieder unter
ich kann jetzt zum aller ersten mal in
meiner kleinen hobbit heute hier
schlafen und ich würde an der stadt auch
sagen meine lieben freunde wenn euch das
video gefallen hat das kind einen daumen
hoch unter dem tier hier da aber nimmt
einen kanal und klickt auf die glocke
wenn die neue episoden nicht verpassen
wollt ich muss ganz schnell los so
podcast aufnahme
[Musik]